gregor gysi in berlin
fraktionsvorsitzender der partei die
linke einen schönen guten tag dorthin
guten tag ich grüße sie wie ist denn die
position ihrer partei zu der
abhörskandal affäre und vor allem zu den
vorwürfen gegenüber frank walter
steinmeier
also der satz von gerhard schröder
hinsichtlich der uneingeschränkten
solidarität das heißt ja unkritisch das
heißt ja ungeprüft eben einfach
uneingeschränkt war natürlich verheerend
hatte zwei schlimme folgen die eine
schlimme folge war der afghanistan-krieg
und unsere teilnahme mit toten auf
beiden seiten mit irrsinnigen kosten
ohne dass es irgendeinen nennenswerten
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt in
afghanistan gibt und das zweite war die
erlaubnis an die amerikanischen
geheimdienste hier im kern zu treiben
was sie wollen und das ist damals so
begründet worden und herr steinmeier ist
nicht besonders glaubwürdig wenn er
jetzt die regierung kritisiert und keine
selbstkritik übt allerdings ist die
jetzige regierung auch nicht was
glaubwürdig wenn sie so tut als ob sie
damit nichts zu tun gehabt hätte es ist
eben immer fortgesetzt worden und alle
kanzler leisten ein leiter sind nämlich
zum schutz ihrer bevölkerung antreten
und da stehen und der ist hier nicht
gewährleistet wurden katja kipping
vorsitzende der linke sagt herr
steinmeier sei der größte heuchler in
der ganzen spionage affäre ist das nicht
ein bisschen über das ziel
hinausgeschossen
die drückt sich eben gerne drastisch aus
so kann man sie auch sagen ich würde es
halt anders formulieren aber das liegt
an dem anderen stil den ich habe aber es
ist natürlich nicht besonders ehrlich
wissen sie ich verstehe das auch nicht
auf den us dollar dann kommt er und
erzählt dass das ja alles schon wieder
aufgeklärt ist es gibt doch keinen
anderen weg mehr wir müssen es jetzt
öffentlich machen es gibt keinen anderen
weg als eine vollständige transparenz
herzustellen und zu sagen das ist
gelaufen so ist es passiert und so und
so soll es korrigiert werden wenn wir
das nicht machen wird das vertrauen der
bevölkerung in die politikerinnen und
politiker immer weiter zurückgeht das
nutzt nur niemanden weder jemanden von
union und spd auch uns nicht es nutzt
niemanden transparenz müssen wir jetzt
herstellen in den vergangenen wochen
mehr so das politische berlin beobachtet
hat ja den eindruck die linke geht recht
stark auf die spd zu nun aber dieser
schuss sozusagen gegen den bug der spd
ist denn da die strategie der link
nein unsere strategie ist eine ganz
andere wir sagen was will denn
eigentlich die spd will sie in den
nächsten vier jahren weitere
kriegseinsätze oder wie sie das nicht
will sie dass das rentenniveau gesenkt
bleibt und die rente um zwei jahre
gekürzt werden oder wie sie das
korrigieren will sie die prekäre
beschäftigung aufrecht erhalten will sie
weiterhin dass deutschland
drittstärkster button exporteur der welt
ist will sie hartz4 so belassen wie es
ist oder nicht und dann sagen wir
entweder sie will dass alles so belassen
dann hat sie recht wenn sie sagt sie
macht das mit der union und der fdp oder
der fdp aber wenn sie sagt sie will das
nicht dann müsste sie sich eigentlich
öffnen für die linken denn das gegenteil
davon kann sie nur mit uns durchsetzen
wir machen das doch am inhalt und ich
möchte die spd stellt muss doch mal
sagen was sie wirklich will und mit wem
sie das ganze umsetzen will und ich will
natürlich den leuten auch deutlich
machen gespräche scheitern noch nicht an
uns sondern wenn dann an den anderen
hans peter uhl der unions-innenpolitiker
experte sagt das sei ja auch eine
verleumdung von mitarbeitern der
deutschen geheimdienste aus der herr
steinmeier indirekt macht hat er recht
ach wissen sie ich glaube die können
sich besser schützen die brauchen
wirklich nicht mein schutz sage ich mal
die mitarbeiter der geheimdienste
aber das verhältnis müssen wir doch mal
klären ich meine ich muss ihn mal ganz
ernsthaft sein dass das besatzungsstatut
immer noch gilt wir haben nicht das jahr
1945 wir haben das jahr 2013 könnte man
das nicht mehr aufheben und die
besatzung deutschlands beenden also ich
finde es wird höchste zeit also ein paar
mutige schritte müssen gegangen werden
um mich stört auch dass unsere
bundeskanzlerin ist macht die müsste
jetzt ja eigentlich täglich mit obama
telefonieren und versuchen zu klären um
dann der bevölkerung zu sagen das wird
so und so und dann und dann beendet aber
eine stört man nur jetzt gegenseitige
schuldzuweisungen zwischen wenn man so
will vier parteien die daran beteiligt
waren nämlich union spd fdp und grüne
sie waren ja alle vier daran beteiligt
und das müsste sie zugeben und
offenlegen und dann kann man sich immer
noch darüber streiten wer den größeren
schuld anteil hat also ich sage noch
einmal ich weiß natürlich dass die union
das jetzt macht um der spd eins
auszuwischen und die spd reagiert wie
des öfteren hilflos aber im kern ist es
eingeleitet worden ich sag mal von
dieser männerrunde schröder steinmeier
und fischer das kann man sich auch
vorstellen mit ihm zimmer zusammen
sitzen wie die sowas auskuppeln und dann
denken sie mal sowas kommt nicht raus
nur kurz aber doch raus brust die
nächste regierung und die nächste
regierung hat es doch alles weiter
gemacht wir haben endlich aufgehört
sondern haben das immer weiter passiert
und was soll das überhaupt außerdem bin
ich davon überzeugt dagegen ist nicht
nur am terroristen und terroristen
sondern die werden auch fleißig
wirtschaftsspionage betrieben haben und
deshalb sage ich das misstrauen ist so
tief dass wir im nächsten bundestag
jetzt auch wirklich ein
untersuchungsausschuss dringend
benötigen um klarheit herzustellen um
transparenz herzustellen um diese dinge
zu überwinden meint gregor gysi ganz
herzlichen tag noch nach berlin wird
schön